hey guys welcome back to a new video and
today is going to be more of a
discussion video and before I get
started I just want to let everybody
know if you want me to discuss a certain
topic whether you have a question on
something whether you need to explain
didn't need me to put it in a video just
tell me in the comments flow and I'll
gladly make one for you that's why I'm
here I got to support all of you guys
for now subbing to me and I got to get
back to you anyway today's video is
going to be more on the defensive
metaphor honor if you've gone around
anywhere on the reddit or maybe even in
game people have always talked about the
defensive meta and what it is basically
the reason that it's in the game is
because it's so easy to sit around and
just wait for someone to attack and then
parry them and then punish that player
so for example you could have a
conqueror and earn a row cheese together
in a row Qi tries to do a storm rush but
then [ __ ] up conquer then Perris that
attack and they completely punishes him
for it that's how these matches work
they don't award you for aggression they
reward you for being defensive and
turtling eventually this could this
becomes so boring at any level of play
to where two players are basically
sitting around waiting for one of them
to [ __ ] up an attack like I just said
this is bad on a competitive level you
see now there is no rank but there are
recent tournaments popping up for like
small prize pools and some of the recent
tournaments not all of these fights by
the way some of these fights were
genuinely good but most of the fights
most of some of the fights where people
just waiting for someone to attack and
then parry or some other type of some
other type of defensive maneuvers and
since this is a very well known topic I
thought I'd like to give my opinion on
how to fix this meta now for the first
idea on how to fix this thing blocking
an attack should deduce more stamina as
it stands now blocking attack
practically serves no purpose to
reducing stamina there's practically
none of it if there even is any they
should reduce stamina by the amount of
block attacks you have for basically
making players have to parry although
parrying is very easy but I'll get to
that point later in this and then
hitting someone all
so no are hitting someone who was
blocking also on his chip damage should
do more than what it is because now as
it stands the damage is so small it
doesn't even matter and some of you
probably don't even know that's a
mechanic that if you hit someone and
they're blocking you do small minor chip
damage the damage output for this chip
damage whatever it has to be should
obviously be enough so that the people
can't turtle constantly like a warlord
or conqueror might do or Valkyrie even
but if they're going to have it have the
heavies do more damage and then drain
more stamina it's locked and then the
light attacks do slightly lower than
that thing is the heavies are a lot
slower but more heavy hitting and then
the last thing I have is he Perry's
Perry's are kind of easy and it's
because of that low-risk high-reward if
you miss a Perry oh well you get
attacked but if you if you land that
Perry they get a lot of damage taken
against them and then that's where your
combo starts see it needs to have a
tighter window making it a lot harder to
parry therefore more rewarding to pull
off the problem with this defensive
betta is that people are just going to
like I've been stating wait around for
this attack and then what it should be
doing is rewarding players for how
aggressive they're being doing multiple
combos fainting people into you know
Perry bait or something like that being
more aggressive should be the way that
this meta is not be waiting around for
someone to throw an attack to Perry or
[ __ ] up an attack and dodge around and
punish them this could be the end of the
video today guys if you guys did enjoy
please comment down below what you
thought of it or any of your ideas
regarding the defensive meta and for
honor and then also like I said in the
beginning tell me in the comments below
what other videos you want me to make
for you if you have any other questions
I can answer them or if they need a
video I can dedicate a video to that if
you guys did like the video please be
sure to give it a thumbs up and then if
you're new to this channel please
subscribe I got tons of foreign archons
that come in the Dead streams coming
this week on Friday I'll be covering
that and then any of my other discussion
videos overthrowing out your way anyway
guys have a great day peace out